foreign
[Applause]
questions we get asked here on Journey
to the microcosmos comes from all of you
who are thinking of starting your own
microscopic Journeys and want a little
nudge in the right direction the
question of course is what microscope
should I use and that's a big question
to answer actually our own Journey
Through the microcosmos has meant
traveling through the lenses of a few
different microscopes and that's why if
you've ever seen our earlier videos you
know they look quite a bit different
from what we see today and that is part
of the fun of microscopy a rotifer under
any lens is a thrilling encounter it's
just that the nature of the encounter
shifts with the light that you shine on
it there are so many different ways to
see the world and any microscope can be
the right one if it's helping you get
started with your exploration at the
same time there are things that will
make a microscope more and less easy to
use more and less versatile and we
wanted to make it at least a little bit
simpler for you to kick off your journey
by creating what we think is the best
starter microscope out there the journey
to the micro Cosmos microscope you can
buy it on our store and many of you
already have so if you are asking us
what microscope you should use to start
your journey we have created the
microscope we think is the best one but
of course getting a microscope is just
step one there's a lot to learn along
the way for those of you who are looking
for a little guidance on how to use your
microscope or for those of you who are
just curious about what the microscope
looks like in action well that's what we
are here for today all of the footage
we're showing for the rest of this video
is footage that James and our master of
microscopes has recorded using our
microcosmos microscope and if you don't
have our microscope that's okay most of
the tips we're talking about today
should help you out as you start on your
microscopy Journey no matter what
microscope you choose to start with
we are going to focus on bright field
microscopy which means that we'll be
looking at samples that are illuminated
entirely by white light this is the most
straightforward technique in microscopy
so it's a great place to start and learn
from but just because it's simple does
not mean it isn't powerful the intensity
of the light can render many of our
organisms transparent giving us a view
of the world and structures inside their
bodies like the cells floating around in
our tardigrade here now there are times
when that light might shine a little too
bright and drown out some other things
we might want to see so in the future we
might cover some other filters and
techniques that will demonstrate other
ways to use the microscope now once you
have your microscope set up the next
step is to decide what part of the
microcosmos you want to explore and the
good news is the microcosmos is just
about everywhere you can start out by
collecting some water from a puddle or
nearby Pond or maybe even the saliva in
your mouth anything that has water is
like a little portal waiting to be
opened by your microscope lens
to actually open that portal you will
need to prepare a slide for your
microscope by transferring a small
amount from your sample to a slide the
first few times you might be tempted to
add you know maybe a little too much
water to the slide especially because it
seems maybe a little improbable that you
will find something in a little drop
load of water but microbes are tiny and
so you probably will find something and
too much water will cause the light to
refract which will make it difficult to
make out all the spectacular details
lying within their bodies so you'll want
to try and keep the sample as thin as
possible but also if there's something
in there that you can actually see with
your eyes you shouldn't make it too thin
because you might Crush those organisms
when you add the cover slip which might
be a somewhat dramatic beginning for
your first foray into microscopy it's a
bit of a Goldilocks situation so here's
an example of it correctly and
incorrectly prepared slide to help you
see the difference on the right you see
the water is seeping beyond the borders
of the coverslip because there was just
too much water there the good news of
course is that if you mess up you can
always try again our world is a nearly
Infinite Source of microcosmoses to
experiment with and every mistake is
just a different path the new originally
envisioned now once you have your slide
on the microscope stage the next thing
you want to play around with is how much
light is reaching the slide because that
will influence the quality of the image
you see we with too much light all the
little details like The Ridges along
this pineal area might get washed out
now one thing you can do is just dim the
light source but the tool that's really
going to help you adjust the amount of
light is the condenser diaphragm which
James is helpfully demonstrating here
with the help of his cat as he pushes it
One Direction more light enters the
diaphragm allowing us to see more of the
cat on the other side now instead of a
cat let's see what happens when you
adjust the condenser diaphragm on the
microscope starting out the amoeba
interview is a little dark but when
James opens the condenser too fast a
little details inside of it become
washed out turning the organism into it
like a Blobby circle that has few
distinguishing features but as he closes
the condenser again you start to see the
scaliness of the shell and the fainter
bits of the amoeba that Peak out from
within you might also find your view
interrupted by dust and impurities
coming from the surface of the condenser
or the light source if that happens all
you have to do is adjust the height of
the condenser by adjusting the knob on
the side and if you feel like you're
getting pretty comfortable with your
microscope there's a technique you can
work on to take your journey to a
different level oil immersion
we have a whole video explaining oil
immersion and how it helps you see up
close and personal with some of the most
spectacular organisms but one thing to
know is that you need to be careful not
all objectives can work with oil
immersion and if you use the wrong one
you might actually ruin it and this
technique relies on high magnification
objectives so you'll need to be careful
not to move too quickly if you're not
careful you can cause your objective to
crash into the slide which can break the
slide but also more importantly can
damage the objective
to start you'll want to prepare a slide
like normal you'll just need to really
make sure the sample is very thin before
you add the cover slip then take a drop
of the oil that came with your
microscope and put it on the coverslip
using the 100x objective turn the focus
knob very gently until you see a clear
image now I think that one of the true
joys of the micro Cosmos is going to
share what you find with other people in
fact while watching our Hydra here James
got so excited about something that he
saw that we're gonna be making a whole
episode about it soon unfortunately
unlike the masters of microscopes of
past centuries we have many tools that
make it possible to record our Journeys
and share them with others James does
this by setting up a camera on a tripod
so that the camera looks through the
microscope eyepieces and you can do the
same with a camera or even a phone our
microscope actually comes with a phone
mount to make this a bit easier and if
you record some fun microscopic footage
we would love to see it you can share
your footage with us on social media on
Twitter and Instagram at journey to
micro or we also have a submission form
now on our store where you can submit
footage to possibly be used in a future
episode of Journey to the micro Cosmos
we love being able to share the wonders
of the microscopic world with you every
single week and we hope that this video
helps you out at the beginning of your
own personal Journey Through the Unseen
World that surrounds us if you buy the
microscope it also comes with a series
of videos that will help you on your
sample collection Journeys setting up
the microscope and using it in a bunch
of different ways next week we're going
to be posting another video about our
microscope but this time I'll be on
camera doing a full unboxing video of
our micro Cosmos microscope you'll see
what the microscope will look like when
it arrives and I'll show you how to set
the whole thing up
there's a bunch of names on the screen
right now and that's the names of some
of our patreon patrons the people who
allow us to do the thing that we are
doing right now sharing something truly
remarkable about our universe not just
the fact that we are surrounded by this
invisible world that for the vast
majority of human history was entirely
unknown to us but also advocating for
this as an activity as a journey that
more people can participate in so thank
you so much to all of our patreon
patrons if you want to see more from our
master of microscopes James Weiss you
can check out jam and germs on Instagram
and if you want to see more from us
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby